i'm maria bartiromo i'm greg gutfeld i'm
liz clayman and this is the fox news
rundown
friday may 13th 2022 i'm lisa brady
russia's war in ukraine has been a real
eye-opener for some world leaders there
was this mixed feeling amongst nato
allies with regard to how serious the
threat of russia is
i suspect that's mostly gone away at
this point people realize that putin is
an autocrat and a dangerous person and
we should take him seriously
i'm chris foster the white house is
marking a million american coveted
deaths and warning of a new wave this
fall and winter we need to study the
biggest public health intervention in
human history so that we don't repeat
many of the mistakes that resulted in a
mental health crisis
and i'm will kane and i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
it took less than three months for
decades of strategy to unravel in europe
with russian president vladimir putin
blaming security concerns on western
nations while launching a war in ukraine
that's laid waste to cities displaced
millions of people and led to
international condemnation sanctions and
allegations of war crimes even genocide
it may also end up expanding nato i
think we've been communicating also to
the russians that this may someday
happen and i think now the day has come
nikahatali is finland's ambassador to
the u.s finland which has europe's
longest border with russia and has
collaborated with nato for decades now
drawing an angry reaction from moscow
for its intention to apply for
membership sweden ready to take the
plunge too the white house says it would
support both applications this as
congress works on billions more dollars
to help ukraine we've been very clear
that we want to continue to help
the people of ukraine and the ukrainian
armed forces defend themselves and so
that is going to require some additional
resources pentagon spokesman john kirby
says there's no telling how long the war
could last with fighting now
concentrated in the eastern donbass
region a shift in strategy made by the
russians after failing to hold gains
elsewhere or to capture the capital cave
this has been a complete strategic
failure for vladimir putin mark esper is
a former u.s defense chief and author of
a new book a sacred oath memoirs of a
secretary of defense during
extraordinary times you know i said on
the day of the invasion and back in late
february that he had already managed to
push
ukraine into nato's orbit he managed to
bring more nato troops onto his border
and he managed to unify nato and that
was before we had any indication that
sweden and finland might pursue alliance
membership which as you suggest are now
in the cusp of doing so look he's filled
all the way around and we're not even we
haven't even spoken about the economic
implications right of
countries around the world cutting off
his coal supply his oil supply and so
his liquid natural gas supply so
anyways it's just been a complete
disaster for him
you know russia's reaction to
finland's announcement in particular
sounds like saber-rattling warning about
military technical steps that could come
in retaliation given the situation in
ukraine though
what remaining military capability
would russia have right now if they
wanted to make some kind of move against
finland
i mean first of all the response has to
be what it is it predictably a little
bit of saber rattling they certainly
can't let it go
and they can't ignore it so they're
gonna have to say something about it but
you're right look they're losing in
ukraine
it's not like they have the means to
start a second front in finland and but
that said as soon as finland and sweden
apply i think we should immediately pull
over top of the umbrella of nato
protection clinically i mean the treaty
application process has to go through
the senate for us and for parliaments
for other countries but that doesn't
mean we can't give them our political
protection and that's what i would do
just to kind of reassure them and push
back on russia
does russia's army
lose all credibility the longer the war
in ukraine goes on or
in terms of its sheer size even
is it still a force
to reckon with like is the world in
danger of going from potentially you
know overestimating russia's military to
maybe underestimating it in some way
we certainly have to be careful of not
doing that right we gotta remember that
they have a strategic nuclear arsenal
that is very capable uh they have a
capable navy
the air force is underperformed clearly
and certainly the army has as well so i
still would not underestimate them but
it's clear that we overestimated their
capabilities and look their problems now
are not just with the ukrainians but you
keep hearing story after story about
russian soldiers themselves refusing
orders sabotaging their own equipment
walking off the battlefield
they are clearly in bad shape right now
you served as defense secretary for a
year under president trump
based on your contacts with foreign
counterparts during that time
are you surprised by russia you know
what they're saying and doing um by the
response in ukraine uh or by the world
reaction and the nato response
well
in some ways you know we we always knew
that putin had this aggressive nature we
saw him invade georgia in 2008 he did
invade ukraine first in 2014 we had
these frozen conflicts if you will and
every time i would travel to brussels
for nato during my 18 months or so as
secretary of defense we would talk about
these issues and concerns and some of us
you know saw that russia was a threat i
mean it was
for me it was one of our top priorities
i i made implementation of the national
defense strategy my number one focus and
that said that
china was our top strategic adversary
followed by russia uh frontline states
in europe such as poland and the baltic
countries felt the same way but other
countries didn't and this was a beef we
had with germany for example not taking
russia as seriously as we thought
president trump was right to push on
them for not living up to their
commitments to spend more on defense for
continuing the
nordstrom 2 project and so
there was this mixed feeling amongst
nato allies with regard to how serious
the threat of russia is
i suspect that's mostly gone away at
this point people realize that putin is
an autocrat and a dangerous person and
we should take him seriously the current
defense secretary lloyd austin you know
says he wants to see russian forces
weakened
have they been weakened significantly
already or is there a long way to go on
that front
well they've clearly been weakened i
mean depending on who's reporting you
believe they've at least lost hundreds
of tanks fighting vehicles artillery
systems thousands upon thousands of
soldiers killed
aircraft shot down both fixed wing or
rotary wing
i mean just the material damage done to
the military is devastating it will take
them years to rebuild if you had it you
know i worked in the defense industry i
know what that's like and then of course
we're talking about the harm done to the
confidence morale the forces itself and
and the generals right their ability to
lead so
when this is all said and done which by
the way may take years there's gonna
have to be a major reckoning within
russia about the future of their
military
with so much focus right now on russia
and the war in ukraine
is the world's paying enough attention
right now to china and is there anything
the u.s military should be doing now to
prevent or prepare for a possible
chinese invasion of taiwan well i do get
concerned about uh
china and lack of focus on that as we as
most countries zero in on russia
and that's obviously the conflict before
us but i'm confident that the us
military is paying close attention
to what's happening in china and keeping
an eye on the taiwan strait where
something like that could happen got to
be careful not to take our eye off that
ball as well because
you bet that both beijing and taipei are
taking lessons learned from what's
happening on the battlefields of ukraine
and wonder wondering what it means for
some type of conflict between taiwan and
china so it's something we need to be
careful of that means beefing up our
defense budgets and i know a lot of
people don't want to hear that but if
you want peace you gotta have peace
through strength so we can preserve this
wonderful international order that has
kept us relatively safe and prosperous
for many years
this august will mark a year since the
chaotic withdrawal from
afghanistan
has the taliban takeover been as
catastrophic as it could have been for
afghans or do we even
you know have a real handle on what's
happening there right now
i think we have a lot of good people in
the government and and civil society as
well who are watching what's happening
in afghanistan i think you know clearly
they are not living up to
the promises they made
you know i read recently where there of
course have denied girls the chance to
go to school beyond a certain level and
now i think i read where they're
requiring women to go back into burqas
wearing burqas so look they're they're
moving backwards which is uh what the
the opposite of what they promised and i
think unfortunately for them for the
people of afghanistan
it's it's it's a return to what it was
uh prior to 2001 and uh i wish it hadn't
happened that way i had opposed a
precipitous withdrawal from afghanistan
uh during my tenure and um we were able
to forestall that sum but
it's it's just not optimistic right now
for the people of afghanistan
you have a book just out this week a
sacred oath memoirs of a secretary of
defense during extraordinary times
in it you're critical of the former
president and especially some of the
ideas he floated
why did you decide to write the book
though rather than for instance to
resign at the time
well it's a great question and i
addressed that in the first few pages of
the uh
of the book
why
do good people
why did they join the administration uh
why did they stay
when conditions got really tough why did
they not resign and that was the issue i
faced you know as as my views
increasingly diverged with president
trump's as i faced some of these
outlandish ideas being proposed by folks
around him and then of course
june 1st when we had unrest in the
streets of dc and the president
proposed that we shoot protesters i
really wrestled with you know what is my
duty what is uh
to whom is my oath and it's very clear
your oath is to the constitution not to
a president not to a party
not to a philosophy and i thought that
as long as i was in office i could
continue to advance a very positive
agenda within the
uh pentagon where we can continue to
modernize the force beef up cyber
command stand up space force propose a
new navy take care of our soldiers uh
service members and families i could do
all these things at the same time
i thought that i could be in place to
push back on bad ideas whether it was
you know putting a quarter million
troops on the southwest border shooting
missiles into our neighbor mexico i've
been very successful in terms of pushing
back on this and proposing other things
and so
i thought my higher calling was to do
that and i wrestled with this i spoke to
my wife friends
consulted frankly with
predecessors from both parties uh
previous sex deaths and and to include
the late general colin powell to a
person they all said look you gotta stay
and
the other the other factor was i didn't
know who was coming in behind me and i
was very concerned it would be you know
an uber loyalist if you will who would
who would act on some of these uh
outlandish ideas so it's for all these
reasons that um
you know i stayed it doesn't mean i
didn't wrestle with it it would have
been far easier for me to kind of walk
away but i just didn't think that was
the right thing to do
just one other thing i'm wondering if
you think the us is
ready for the wars of the future um
cyber warfare for instance
you know you have to you know poke your
way through each of the domains of
warfare as we say it um so i think in
cyber warfare for example we have
a
very good capability the best in the
world no doubt the question is do we
have sufficient numbers of those and
sufficient authorities and i think we
could you know that was a question i
would raise but i think we have great
capability there we have very good
capability in space and and are getting
better and i think the establishment of
the space force and space command of the
trump administration was a real step
forward a positive one and we will
continue to build those capabilities um
i feel strong at the armies on the right
path the uh
the other services as well i'm very
concerned about the navy however we
don't have in my view the right number
the right types of ships uh the right
capacity to deal with china
in the indo-pacific in the 21st century
so that's my biggest area of concern i
think there's a lot more in terms of
preparing for the future that we could
do and should do and i just don't see
that we're there yet
former defense secretary mark esper best
of luck to you with the new book and
thanks again for your time
thank you very much
[Music]
this is will kane with your fox news
commentary coming up
president biden's marking a million
american coven 19 deaths ordering
american flags thrown at half staff at
federal buildings
today
we mark a tragic milestone here in the
united states
one million covets
one million empty chairs around the
family dinner table each
irreplaceable
irreplaceable losses the president there
addressing a global virtual covet summit
hosted by the white house his
administration is predicting a big wave
of cases and deaths this coming fall and
winter and pushing for more vaccination
testing and treatment options the real
number of coveted deaths of course will
never be known and depends on who you
count whether or not it's
850 000 or 1.1 million it's a tragedy
and either way it's a significant
significant milestone that we're around
dr marty mccary is a fox news medical
contributor and johns hopkins university
professor my concern is that we still
don't measure accurately deaths for
covid versus with covid and
hospitalizations with covet versus
incidental you know four covet and that
kind of distinction and that as a result
a lot of these debates are gonna cycle
back in the winter next year when we
definitely will see a bump in cases uh
who knows to what degree but we really
should know that number what is the best
metric of the pandemic it's
hospitalizations for covet yeah i mean
the administration is saying we might
get 100 million covert infections on
this in a wave of death this coming fall
in winter and as we've talked about
before at this point case numbers aren't
nearly as meaningful as they used to be
if they ever were i mean
for most of us at least uh who people
who are vaccinated people have natural
immunity um it's hospitalizations and
deaths that we should be looking at
right
that's right and i'm glad you bring that
up because you will see a number of ways
numbers can be manipulated say for
example
a 300 percent increase in coveted cases
next winter you know that could mean
that the case average is going from
nine to twenty one per hundred thousand
so i think people need to recognize
cases are not the right measure look
most people will develop five to twenty
infections at some point
in their young life and we don't say you
have a
500 to 2 400 percent chance of getting
coveted we say look this is a
seasonal thing and it's mild the vast
majority of the time and for people who
have immunity to covet we know you have
a 99.99
level of protection against severe
illness and death do you ever expect the
kind of numbers that would lead to a
return to
mass mandates or work from home policies
or shutting down schools policies and
what's the metric there just if
hospitals get so slammed or if
businesses are just so short-staffed or
schools or social staffed well that
should be the metric but unfortunately
if you look at the cdc's metric for
determining what's a low medium or high
level of covet risk they're still using
case counts as part of that
unfortunately
that's very concerning and i do think
you're going to see some places probably
in the blue states
retreat into
zero coveted strategies like school
closures next year ignoring the fact
that we really
have not had good data in the united
states and in the in europe we've seen
schools open free and clear with no
differences in transmission rates big
study just done in finland looked at
provinces where there was so schools
open wide and clear versus mast
and there was absolutely no difference
in transmission we need to study the
biggest public health intervention in
human history so that we don't repeat
many of the mistakes that resulted in a
mental health crisis yeah i mean you
you can clear this up uh or expound on
it you tweeted something about um the
lack of national institutes of health
funds at the beginning of the pandemic
actually going toward research of the
pandemic right i mean
so
that just led to the zone getting
flooded with all these opinions
and half truths or untruths because the
research just wasn't there
i have a lot of patients and
friends ask me how did this become so
politicized let me tell you the original
sin of the covet pandemic was that when
the infection came to the united states
dr fauci and dr collins at the nih
failed to fund the clinical research
quickly to settle the unanswered
questions they could have done it in 24
hours or within one week for some of
these questions how does it spread is it
airborne or surface
do masks work cloth masks versus quality
masks
what's the um
most contagious period when's the peak
of viral shedding how long do you have
to quarantine for those questions could
have been answered in a week they were
not our study out of hopkins that just
was published
i showed that they issued less than two
percent of their grants in the year of
the pandemic to study coveted clinical
research um they have 50 billion dollars
roughly and they really did not study
code research in a timely fashion they
failed to pivot so as a result we had a
void of scientific data and what filled
that void
was opinions public opinions political
opinions and medical group think that
drove our policy not scientific data
that drove our policy
the but administration is pushing
congress for more money is there
anything here that we actually can throw
money at that would be
helpful like ventilation in schools
where it's possible etc etc is there
something that money can do
look we've thrown a ton of money for
schools to improve their ventilation and
that money came a year ago and where do
we stand today we still were still
having the same debates we had last time
so
sometimes throwing good money after bad
actually does not change the situation
is there political will is a priority is
the money managed well or poorly
that's where we need to look at our
spending we need to spend our money in a
way that's smart
the 23 billion dollar proposal right now
to increase covet funding on top of all
the billions we've spent already
is not a wise
allocation of that amount of money for
example much of it will go towards
the hyper testing industry this testing
industrial complex that over tests
immune young students and other people
like crazy all the time
it's not a great use of public health
funds especially when you have women who
can't get prenatal vitamins in part of
the country and a shortage on formula
for babies
some of that money is going to go to pax
lavid in low-risk vaccinated people with
that study that shows paxolvid save
lives was in high high-risk unvaccinated
people so we're spending money on what
we call low value care and final point
they say it's for another version of the
vaccine
that has not even been disclosed or
under review at the fda so let's wait
until we get that vaccine and then
decide if we want to purchase it
we are back to
um at least in some areas a shortage of
tests and there are there's a lot of kid
crud going around and we'll get into
that where people might say look my
kid's been sick for a week it might be
the flu it might be a cough it might be
a cold or it might be covered that i
want to know just to be a responsible
citizen here but
you can't find a test
well in some cases we need to test to
figure out whether or not they've are
going to have subsequent natural
immunity
but this hyper testing of everybody for
just one of the 20 respiratory viruses
that circulate in society sometimes
represents the medicalization of
ordinary life
and so we've not really accepted the
fact that respiratory viruses do cause
common cold like symptoms and circulate
so i would say what we're doing is not
in a situation where we don't have
enough tests we're misallocating tests
over testing people who are already
immune and extremely low risk and have
no reason to be tested
where are you with mass on public
transportation at this point
look i think if anybody has symptoms or
they're exposed or extremely high risk
they should wear a mask and we know one
way masking is extremely effective that
was the failure the biden policy and a
lot of the masking policy was the
failure to recognize that we should not
have an all or nothing strategy masks
should be used selectively
for those who have symptoms or exposed
or high risk yeah but then you're
trusting those people to actually do it
that's right there's no good solution
sometimes but that is where we land uh
the recommendation now is for a booster
if you're over 50
the federal recommendation i mean yours
i want to get yours or if you're
particularly high risk what do you tell
people on the lower end of that scale
people who are healthy people in their
50s say do you get a do is it worth it
to get a booster and if so when when is
the when is it most advantageous to do
so
well i can tell you the fda's own
advisory committee was not on board with
fourth doses in people 50 to 65 pfizer
actually only applied for the fourth
dose in people over 65 but the fda oddly
granted them the authorization for
people all the way down to age 50. and
all the studies ignored natural immunity
that is a powerful deterrent against
covid if you've had covid you probably
don't need a booster and if you're over
age 65 and you had covered recently i
don't think you need a fourth dose but
for people who have not had covet and
they're over 65 i do recommend a booster
i remember you've criticized before that
you think the timelines are too
compressed do you think that this chart
should be more spread out
that's right we got the interval wrong
with good intentions they tried to get
the studies done quickly so they put the
first two doses of the vaccine just
three and four weeks apart there's no
vaccine out there we give that close
together when you spread them out
further eight weeks or 12 weeks apart
you have lower side effects and better
immunity and that's what we should have
recommended a long time ago actually the
cdc just recently
issued that recommendation said look try
to space them out by about eight weeks
they did it quietly it was almost to
save face ironically it was after 270
million people got the vaccine
um i mentioned kid crud i've had a
minorly sick kid and i talked to my
pediatrician
and he said 20 of his patients have
reported or their parents reported
having fevers calls are coming in left
and right
does my kid have kobe what does my kid
have
is this just
as simple as kids weren't exposed for a
couple years if they were in schools
with masks for example it it does seem
and there's a growing thought that
because we put kids and a lot of
americans in a bubble for nearly two
years that now the people are out and
about they do have some sort of
increased susceptibility we've been
bracing for a long time for example for
a really bad flu season luckily the
virus circulating right now
is at levels we normally see at this
point in a flu season and not worse but
there is something to increase
susceptibility when you've been
sheltered for so long from respiratory
pathogens that give you low level
exposure and possibly some level of
immunity
and
has it been a weird flu season i
understand that things are peaking a
little bit late
that's right we're about where we
normally are during a flu season people
forget that there's a whole bunch of
respiratory viruses that circulate
rsv coxsackie virus
a whole group of different viruses that
cause common cold like illnesses so it
can be difficult to distinguish the
reason to get covert tested is to know
that you've got good natural immunity
against covet at least the current
variant and you can feel good about that
once you've recovered dr marty mccary
johns hopkins university professor of
public health policy and management and
surgery the author of several books
including the price we pay what broke
american healthcare and how to fix dr
mccary thank you very much again
good to be with you chris
[Music]
from the fox news podcast network
download and listen to the untold story
with martha mccallum the host of the
story on fox news channel sits down with
major newsmakers each week to get their
untold story subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
more than 100 graduates of wiley college
won't have student debt to worry about
anymore
at graduation last weekend the school's
president hermann j felton jr announced
that an anonymous donor had paid off
their debt which was a combined 300
thousand dollars you are debt free
you do not owe the college a penny
if you have a balance you had
a balance
in a news release felton said the school
communicates with donors to help pay off
student loans so graduates can start
their after college experience with less
debt
wiley is a private historically black
college and was founded in 1873 in
marshall texas about 40 miles west of
shreveport louisiana it's also the
school whose 1935 debate inspired the
2007 film the great debaters which start
denzel washington tanya j powers fox
news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
will kane
what's on your mind a conspiracy
of gossip
a house of lies
from where
did russia russia russia
originate
special counsel john durham's
investigation into the origins of the
russia collusion hoax the indictment in
the media
the former president donald trump was in
collusion with vladimir putin in
collusion with russia to swing an
american election
where in fact
did that
hoax originate that's the question for
special counsel john durham it is
proceeding slowly methodically but i
think intentionally and right now it
appears there are two avenues to finding
the origins of russia russia russia on
one hand there is the prosecution of
michael sussman the former clinton
campaign attorney who took information
to the fbi manufactured computer-driven
data to the fbi without telling the fbi
that he represented hillary clinton and
saying hey you might need to look into
donald trump on the other hand a
conspiracy of gossip
three
colleagues three work friends get
together for a drink in europe and share
gossip second hand knowledge third hand
knowledge about what might have gone
down in a hotel in russia with one of
the most famous men on the planet donald
trump that gossip makes its way
unverified unchecked uninvestigated
to christopher steele igor d'anchenko
was one of the members of that gossip
drink circle happy hour and he passed it
to christopher steele christopher steele
laundered that through cia spook
language and turned it into the steele
dossier
buzzfeed's news cycle was born and a
conspiracy was birthed john durham
tracking
two different lanes that lead to the
origins of russia russia russia we can
only hope when you pull on those two
strings you get to the ultimate place of
accountability who benefited
who was behind who hired who employed
who originated russia russia russia i
think we'll find the answer
is clinton
for more of this investigation in the
coming weeks subscribe to the will kane
podcast
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
living the bream is a podcast hosted by
fox news channel's shannon breen sharing
inspirational stories personal anecdotes
and an insider's perspective on actions
and rulings from the high court find it
now on apple podcasts google play and
foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes